et nous sommes en direct avec jean
michel un fauvergue député la république
en marche 8e circonscription de
seine-et-marne ancien patron du raid
bonsoir jean michel robert merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france près
de 800000 verbalisation ans pour non
respect du confinement plus de 12
millions et demi de contrôle depuis le
17 mars le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est
que les forces de l'ordre ne forment pas
une réaction sur ces chiffres c'est que
effectivement échangent leurs rôles
chine pas mais elle sonne pas parce
qu'elles ont raison de ne pas tirer et
c'est bien dommage que l on soit réduite
p recettes et les réalisations
ça veut dire qu'à un certain confinement
et est tout même jean-michel fauvergue
avec des histoires parfois poignante
dont les médias se sont fait le relais
verbalisation d'un homme notamment vous
le dire adieu à son père mourant la
gendarmerie a regretté depuis une femme
du tarn de 93 ans qui voulait
communiquer avec son mari au pied d'une
fenêtre d'un ehpad entre temps aussi
avec la médiatisation le pv a été
annulée mais on peut se poser la
question sur les autorités n'outrepasse
pas un petit peu leurs droits en ces
temps difficiles alors celle et ont
appelé les autorités
là vous savez que le pouvoir de
verbaliser partie aux gens des quartiers
civelli cipal aussi l'association
particulier de mettre de ne pas l'être
ce sens que c'est vers là il a ce
pouvoir a mais effectivement les quelque
10 des cas où l'appréciation et c'est a
été faux cils plantiers mais la plupart
des cas les folies il faut quand même
leur poney dans les les 90% du travail
que policiers et gendarmes policiers
municipaux dans cette verbalisation live
et ce compte
ce confinement est nécessaire pour cette
épidémie est bien la plupart du temps
les policiers et les pompiers municipaux
travaillent bien et au contact et on
peut pas à la fois un reportage sur sur
d'autres chaînes comme sushi qui se doit
départ sur la défense des policiers
d'ici avec la difficulté qui travaillent
vous le devenez du côté et de l'autre
côté leur reprocher de faire leur
travail c'est pas aussi alors 70% en
tout cas des appels au 17 concernent des
signalements de citoyens se sont et le
certificat policiers alternative qui
fournit ce chiffre dont les forces de
l'ordre qui bénéficient d'un soutien
clair des citoyens français qui entre
guillemets donc dénonce les mauvais
comportement de leur père ça vous étonne
ça je suis pas vraiment étonné de ce
type de comportement là que moi j'ai
connu en tant que policier dont les
chefs de la police
on a des certains en tout cas en six
étaient d'avis mais là ça n'est pas
aussi comme tout le reportage il faut
pas généraliser absolument pas mais
voilà c'est un chic et c'est un fait
statistique
acceptons et c'est pas dans ses pas
uniquement dans notre pays change en
michel faubert veuillez nous excuser on
va devoir malheureusement interrompt
cette interview parce que ça arrive
parfois la qualité du réseau internet
qui doit être beaucoup sollicité en ces
temps est assez mauvaise et on vous
entend assez mal en tout cas merci à
vous d'avoir été en direct et d'avoir
répondu à nos questions sur rt france
merci à vous